[Musik]
englisch ist willkommen bei myvideo.de
arbeite ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
er hat sich wahrscheinlich schon am
titel gelesen um was es heute geht
ungefähr vor einem jahr kann man bis
jetzt erfolgreichstes video online und
zwar waren das die berühmtesten musicals
der welt hat mittlerweile fast zwei
millionen klicks glaube ich auf jeden
fall mehr als dankeschön an dieser
stelle und deswegen habe ich mir als
ganz besonderes überlegt wir machen
heute die berühmtesten musicals aus 2000
das haben wir 17
ich komme mittlerweile voll
durcheinander mit dem jahr weil früher
hat man immer in der schule das jahr
noch dahinter getrieben
aber jetzt mache ich das irgendwie fast
nie die leute ihr konntet mir auf
snapshot ganz viel zu schicken ich habe
jetzt folgendes problem gehabt
ich habe nämlich keine kopfhörer womit
ich das jetzt gleich live gucken kann
deswegen habe ich mir hier so ein ja ist
auf jeden fall sind das krasse kopfhörer
ist nur etwas kompliziert ist ein sehr
langes kabel was ich hier habe und ich
muss das jetzt erst mal anschließen ich
hoffe auch mal dass das funktioniert
wieso ist das kabel so lange würde ich
jetzt echt so das video aufnimmt meine
damen und herren herzlich willkommen an
bord des airbus a330 der air berlin die
gibt's gar nicht mehr ganz herzlich
begrüßen auch unserem flug nach mallorca
auf mallorca erwartet und seien völlig
trocken ist oder wann klima und ein
katholischer von 28 grad wird die not ja
auch ein cooler dapd alex ist bereit
lassen doch nach oben da auf jeden fall
wenn ihr bock gehabt dass ich das noch
mal machen steht mir weitere zu die halt
wirklich krass bekannt sind ich sag mal
so bei 13.500 tun und wir fangen an mit
dem ersten was sie mir geschickt habt
let's go
[Musik]
rosina also auf jeden fall recht gut ich
kann jetzt gar nicht sagen weil er mir
das ja geschickt habt ob das wirklich so
krass bekannt ist also ich kann das
jetzt halt nicht das beste wenn so leute
wir kommen zum nächsten und zwar ist das
von münchen
das ist von den job bringt twins die
hatte ich schon mal irgendwo drin
sie sind auf jeden fall eine echt mega
krass so die können gute tricks auf
wertsachen so ich halte mein headset auf
und wir schauen uns das mal an was sie
heute so für uns vorbereitet haben weil
ich sehe dass jetzt schon dass die das
sind
[Musik]
also normalerweise machen die coole
sachen das ist jetzt sehr einfach gerade
erst ist er einen typen ablaufen aber da
muss ich mir noch mal angucken
[Musik]
also ist auf jeden fall ganz cool ich
habe letztens irgendwann mal einen
bericht darüber gelesen das halt dann
sehr oft so affen wirklich schlecht
gehalten werden nur mit touristenvisum
foto zu machen ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
es hier aussieht aber diese affen
scheint da ganz glücklich zu sein
deswegen finde ich das ganz cool ich hab
so burkhard 1,4 millionen likes ich
glaube bei meinem ersten part also die
berühmten musical ich der welt hatte das
bekannteste 11 millionen
seid ihr noch auf miese kollektiv
schweiz in die kommentare ich nicht
eigentlich soll ich mal wieder was
kosten so leute kommen wir zum nächsten
[Musik]
ich finde das immer so schade so was zum
beispiel hat dann halt ne millionen
likes oder zwei millionen likes und was
kann die gar nix ich verstehe dann zum
beispiel auch gar nicht warum das so
vielleicht also mich unterhält das
wirklich so 0 meinen trampolinspringen
im batman kostüm kann irgendwie jeder
stelle mich gar nicht darüber aufregen
wir machen einfach weiter und zwar habe
ich folgendes bekommen ich wusste gar
nicht dass selena gomez ein musical
account hat aber den hat sie und dieses
musical hat 15 millionen leid ich mache
einfach in einem monat so zwischen 4 und
8 millionen youtube klicks und die macht
auch ein musical i 15 millionen likes
nicht news likes also sitcom ist ich bin
gespannt
[Musik]
da
ja
diese
aber ich muss sagen der song der ist
geil
vor allem hier natürlich ist das jetzt
auch nicht wirklich viel da steckt viel
arbeit drin aber man muss sagen das ist
glaube ich will das auch nichts falsches
lang habe ich meine wer von ihr wart ja
15 millionen likes auf selena gomez
nicht schlecht ich glaube damit bis zu
einer spitze falls das nicht so ist
lasst es mich wissen schickt mir das zu
einfach an meine e-mail alex wie mail at
web.de und meine damen und herren wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten auch
anscheinend von einer sehr bekannten
jungen hübschen attraktiven leute ich
bin jetzt ich will dj warten jetzt sehe
ich wenigstens gut aus wie sandy soja
wir lauren graham ich nicht aber ich bin
jetzt mal gespannt
[Musik]
kreuser ich höre gerade das ist vorlaut
ja weiß ich jetzt nicht also ich will
ich will jetzt nicht sagen das ist mir
nicht gefallen hat so aber man sieht auf
jeden fall dass sie sich ziemlich gut
bewegen kann und das ist ja eigentlich
auch der sinn 1,7 millionen fast so
viele likes wie man meist gesehenes
video an kriegs kopf voran ex so das
habe ich auch noch zugeschickt bekommt
kenne ich jetzt auch möglich
[Musik]
diese lektion also keine ahnung wie das
ist aber es sah nicht schlecht dass ich
finde immer wenn alleine irgendwo auf
einer party war steht der so tanzt sie
das bisschen komisch aus aber zu zweit
habt ihr gut gemacht
weiter geht's so komme ich zum nächsten
1,4 millionen likes christen handy kann
ich kann dich du hast deinen hund hinein
gesperrt also ich habe ja keinen hund
aber ist es normal dass man seinen
hunden so einen kleinen käfig tut die
brauchen doch immer so ein bisschen aus
lauf kann natürlich auch sein dass er
daraus schöpfen kann
aber schöner trend hier ich bin noch gar
nicht fertig
[Musik]
irgendwie muss man ja sagen um erfolg zu
haben musst du einfach nur gut aussehen
das war sie steht halt da und den halt
da finde ich trotzdem ganz nett
anzuschauen so leute zum schluss haben
wir hier noch habe ich jetzt eigentlich
schon alle danach 4,5 millionen likes
auf lisa und lena let go
[Musik]
also vor diesem tanzen mit diesen
handbewegung habe ich echt respekt weil
das ist echt schwierig kann es gerne
versuchen mitzumachen
[Musik]
und ja ich weiss nicht schlecht das
waren einige der berühmtesten musicals
2017 schickte weiter an die e-mail wir
sind es wahrscheinlich dass sonntag
wieder checkt auf jedenfalls dürfte und
instagram auf musical heißt die alex
alex ich kann aber auch nichts das muss
ich sagen also leute sonntag haut rein